you bet your ass is important okay I
don't want to be having a revolving door
coaches here I want to try to make the
best decision I can be and make it you
know the best decision possible
and you know hopefully we can have
somebody here for a long while I kind of
sounded like Jack Nicholson and a few
good men there when he finally crapped
you bet your ass I ordered the Code Red
David Tepper making an important higher
and the hires been made in Peter King
Matt rule the Baylor coach becomes the
head coach in Carolina David Tepper said
yesterday that Matt rule is his Chuck
null hey David let's set the
expectations a little more reasonably
for a guy who had one year in the NFL as
an assistant offensive line coach I
don't think Matt rule wants to carry
around this burden that he's going to
become a four-time Super Bowl winner in
a decade the difference between hiring a
coach in 1969 and hiring a coach 50
years later is very simple there aren't
the secrets that there were you can't go
into predominantly black colleges and
and be smarter than everybody else which
the Pittsburgh Steelers in the Kansas
City Chiefs were they were way ahead of
everybody and there aren't that many
secrets now which is one of the reasons
why I thought when Mike McCarthy told me
three weeks ago that he was all in on
analytics and wanted a 14 person
analytics / video department that owners
were gonna hear that like David Tepper
and say whoa now that interests me and
Mike look I think there are two stunning
things about Matt rule not that he's an
NFL head coach but he got the best first
contract that an NFL head coach you know
has ever gotten I'm talking about a
first time NFL head coach I'm not
talking about Gruden you know I'm
talking about the guys who get hired for
the first time and here they go seven
years sixty-two million
Mike I I'm hey look it's an owners money
you can do whatever he wants to do with
it but all I'm saying is that what
happens after three years if you know
they're four twelve five and eleven
three and thirteen Matt rules getting
fired you know he's not gonna be coming
back for a fourth year and then they're
gonna on whatever 40 million bucks and
whatever all of that is fine I think the
issue is all owners think that they have
the answer it could well be the David
Tepper has the answer in Matt rule I
think he is a very good candidate but
you know what Mike I wrote my column on
Monday of this week of all of the
coaches who graduated from college
football to the NFL in this century so
far the first 20 years I'm not including
guys who cut their teeth in the NFL like
Bill O'Brien or Pete Carroll but all the
other guys who went from college
football to the NFL only one of them has
ever won a playoff game in the NFL and
that's Jim Harbaugh Nick Saban was 15
and 17 and bailed and and so III like
Matt rule don't get me wrong but the
mania over Matt rule is a little bit
weird to me well and Jim Harbaugh
actually had some very deep NFL roots as
a player too so it's not like you know I
mean Matt rule has one year as an
assistant offensive line coach with the
New York Giants that's it he didn't play
for a decade plus like Jim Harbaugh so
it's even more of an outlier and I think
the Chip Kelly experience may have
caused teams to go the other way away
from college candidates Greg Schiano did
not thrive for very long or very well
with Sam Bay Buccaneers there is a
calculated risk here and I want to get
back Peter to the idea that David Tepper
has blown up the coaching entry-level
salary curve you know there's an
unspoken reality among owners that even
though there's no salary cap for coaches
they don't pay coaches what they're
truly worth if nick foles
is worth 22 million dollars per year
there are seven eight nine coaches at
least worth as much or more but that's
not what happens and I was told
yesterday - there's an interesting
dynamic we never quite know exactly
what coaches make because there are
other entities that are owned by the
owner of the team that funnel money to
the coach and some of these guys are
north of 15 million dollars a year and
we don't know it but for entry-level
coaches the prevailing number is 5 to 7
million so now that number's up north of
8 close to 9 million a year you're gonna
have other guys like josh mcdaniels take
notice and Peter you're gonna have guys
like Sean McVeigh who just did an
extension a few months ago thinking what
the hell did I do
and you're gonna have guys like Col
Shannon saying I got three years left on
my deal and I'm worth more than Matt
rule I've proven it this year when do I
get my next contract and this could
spark a little bit of an arms race among
owners and they're gonna resent it
they're gonna be upset with David Tepper
he's gonna get the cold shoulder when
they get together in Florida in two
months you know Mike you make two good
points number one David temper is not a
member of the boys club yet he just
isn't he hasn't been in a lot of owners
meetings he hasn't had that you know the
Jerry Jones arm around the shoulder hey
be careful what you pay or whatever eat
it he's not in that in that thing yet so
but I think there's one other thing that
you said here that's really important
let's think about the people who had
leverage in recent years in the NFL
Kyle Shanahan and John Lynch had
leverage because the 49ers stunk and Jed
York was desperate six-year contracts
Wow unbelievable
Joe Douglas with the New York Jets he
had leverage he I don't think he was
gonna take that job until they got to
the six-year mega dollars range
generational wealth his people would say
now the same thing with Matt rule why
did Matt rule make this money I am
convinced that it's because two things
were at play he had tremendous long-term
assurance of great wealth relatively
speaking at Baylor with significantly
less pressure than he will have with the
Carolina Panthers so he could have
stayed there and had whatever he had
left on his contract seven or eight
years and he could have made whatever
five or six
millionaire but with all these
escalators that all these college
coaches have and there's one other point
about this also Matt rule had the New
York Giants who wanted to talk to him
and there were all sorts of rumors out
there that he was number one on the
Giants list and my guy I
he might have been number one mentally
on their list but they hadn't talked to
him yet they barely knew Matt rule and
so they needed to sit down and talk to
him but when they were called and told
what the money was like they said we're
not doing that and and I was on with
Chris Russo yesterday on his talk show
and he was screaming about it who cares
it's not a salary cap money and I get
that I totally understand that but what
happened if you asked for 12 years 130
million would you say the same thing and
so at some point you have to say the
biggest contract ever and this guy's
been an assistant coach over and
incoming coach you know a rookie coach
and and and he's and he's coach one year
in the NFL it's just hey look they could
well be right and you're right the money
doesn't apply to the cap it's a
tremendous amount of money and a
tremendous commitment to Matt rule
there's been a little hint a little
whiff a little tinge of collusion when
it comes to what coaches make over the
past 30 or 40 years we've seen the
revenues skyrocket the player salaries
go through the roof the coaches have not
kept pace at that same percentage growth
and that's why David Tepper is gonna get
the not the arm around the shoulder
maybe the foot in the rear end
especially from John Mara who didn't
even get a chance to talk to Matt rule
because David Tepper was taking the
entry-level salary structure and blowing
it up it's gonna be an issue for Tepper
because you're right he's not a member
of the boys club yet and it may be
harder for him to become one now that he
has potentially lit the fuse on an
explosion of Coach salary
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports